[Applause]
[Music]
Mexico is in fashion in Hollywood while
Donald Trump keeps trying to build the
wall at the southern border Mexican
movie directors have won five out of the
past six Oscars for Best Director
but as talented as Mexicans are in the
film industry they are far less lucky
when it comes to politics
[Music]
a year ago we told you how the country
of guillermo del toro ended up having
years of bipartisan politics that led to
rampant corruption for a better
understanding the country's latest
presidents on recap union yet to left
office with the worst ratings any
Mexican president has ever had and this
is how the new president began his term
of course we're talking about Andres
Manuel Lopez Obrador also known as an lo
the New Mexican left-wing rock star is
the first president to win more than 30
million votes that's a landslide victory
and it's even more surprising if we take
into account that he didn't come from
either of the two major political
parties Mexicans wanted a radical change
and that's exactly what amlo promised
the question is now is he delivering and
Eric is gonna give us the answer truth
be told yes things are changing in
Mexico and they're changing for the
worse the GDP growth rate was 2% in 2018
but in 2019 they're only projected to
grow about 0.2% yes so far it seems like
Mexico is heading towards a recession
and yes yes I know what you're thinking
come on Simon the brand-new Mexican
president hasn't even been in office for
a year we really blame them for what's
going on in the country well today we
are going to answer this question but
before we do let's take a look back at
the history
the revenant yes I'm sure many of you
have watched the movie the revenant the
Mexican director Alejandro Gonzalez
Inarritu
won his second Oscar for Best Director
with that film but the real revenant in
this story is an lo he started his
career as a member of one of those two
big Mexican political parties the
Institutional Revolutionary Party also
known as the PRI this used to be the
country's big center-left party but AMLO
soon realized that this party wasn't far
enough so I left with him so he created
his own spin-off that led him to become
mayor of Mexico City
this is how amlo became famous
nationwide then in 2006 he ran for
president but lost by 250,000 votes
instead of accepting these results Amla
started several protests and his
supporters claims that he was the
legitimate president then he ran again
for president in 2012 with even worse
results at the time it really looked as
if his career was over
yes nobody would invest a penny in
amylose future but then against the odds
he rose from the ashes with a brand new
political party arena his program was
very simple destroy everything the
previous administrations had done in
Mexico and start from scratch
[Music]
hands well boy in a country so
politically dysfunctional and corrupt
and poverty-stricken as Mexico this
formula couldn't have worked better
let's be honest here an low isn't
disappointing anyone you see in Mexico
after winning the elections you have to
wait five months before you really start
being president during this time they
would be president just wait but Ann
will use this five months to hold lots
of referendums his idea was that as soon
as he started his term he would already
have a list of popular policies ready to
be implemented and so now you might say
well that doesn't sound like such a bad
idea I mean you guys official policy
you've already praised direct democracy
in countries like Liechtenstein and
Switzerland so I mean you're gonna be
back am like that's right
[Music]
and yes you're right referendums can be
pretty cool but they must have
guarantees and be organized by the
government when a political party
organizes referendums by themselves
without any controls it's usually a bit
of a joke and well this is exactly what
AMLO has been doing for most of these
referendums only about one in five
municipalities actually had voting
cabins and the elections they were so
rigs this oh well I mean just look at
this person could vote four times on the
referendum about the new airport but
this is not the end of the story you see
when we talk about referendums the way
we right the question can have a huge
impact on the outcome in other words if
you change the wording you can easily
manipulate the result for example if I
ask do you agree with increasing old
people's pensions or do you want a
better healthcare system well most of
you are going to say yes and these are
the sorts of questions that the morena
party was asking so how many citizens
voted while most of the referendums had
a turnout of less than 1% about equal to
the percentage of absolute diehard and
low supporters and of course all these
policies at more than 90 percent
approval ratings
of course none of these referendums had
any legal binding but they have been the
perfect wave and low to justify all of
his decisions at the end of the day I
mean he's just doing what citizens want
right so now you might be wondering what
kind of decisions is ambling making
where is an example canceling the
construction of Mexico City's new
International Airport we don't know if
the project was good or bad but the
truth is that it costs thirteen billion
dollars of which five billion were
already spent
so basically Mexico is just thrown five
billion US dollars out of the window and
now you might be wondering well why did
he do that that's easy one of those
referendums are only 1% of the
population voted said that the public
agreed with canceling construction
anyway you can argue that many other
politicians base their policies on polls
but the difference is that
amlo sees this as a real legal
instrument going to govern like this
asking the people they say that in order
to make mistakes the best policy is to
ask this is democracy it's not the
decision of one man or two or three
again the problem is not making
referendums in fact a Mexican law
already has legislation in place to
regulate how to make popular
consultations but of course you need an
independent body to run the process and
you need to reach a certain turnout
until this year 2019 this turnout was 40
percent of voters but of course them
Loeb has already changed this now 25
percent is enough twenty-five percent of
Mexican voters is around twenty million
people but there are consultations in
which less than 1 million people voted
in other words for AMLO direct democracy
is pretty undemocratic but wait a minute
because we aren't done yet porphyrin
consultations what does AMLO done in the
few months since he's been in power well
he's been pretty busy check it out
mmm low world avenues presidency can be
summarized in one iconic gesture unlike
its predecessors he didn't want to live
in the Los Pinos palace oh you might say
well that's great he's a man of the
people but the question is why do you
think he went instead do you remain at
home no of course not he went to the
National Palace in other words he just
switched one palace for the other and
what you think he did with the Las Pinas
palace the palace has now become a
cultural center the first big event was
a public screening of Romo the movie
directed by Alfonso Cuaron in order to
promote Mexican movies and in this
regard we must admit he was pretty
transparent
the Ministry of Culture will have to
report how much they spend in popcorn
and punch during the projection of Roma
in Los Pinos okay okay the let's be
clear projecting Roma in the las piñas
palace is not a bad thing but it's not a
good thing either but what actually has
negative consequences for the economy
and does scare investors away are
decisions like canceling the
construction of the airport and changing
all the deals the previous government
had signed with private contractors and
this explains news like this
Mexico Falls eight positions in the
foreign direct investment ranking also
Mexico fell to the last position in the
ranking prepared by a teacher named and
the same goes for energy reform you see
after decades of having a state monopoly
the Mexican oil company Pemex couldn't
be more corrupt they had an enormous
amount of debt and if it wasn't for the
government sport they would have gone
bankrupt years ago the previous
president yet so opens the market for
foreign investments he started by
auctioning the smallest oil fields off
to anybody who wanted to exploit them
the goal was to increase production and
generate more money the first thing
Ambler did as soon as he got into office
was freeze all those public auctions he
wants Mexico's oil industry to remain
the way it was and this is a problem
because the country has a big management
issue in this regard for example even
though Mexico has oil reserves it
imports 70% of its gasoline from the
United States which leads to higher gas
prices
why is it important so much whilst
mainly because Pemex is so mismanaged
that their production Falls every year
so how is Emily trying to solve this
well of course by building a brand new
refinery the problem Pemex has no money
and mexico isn't growing so well why is
he gonna get the money well it's very
good question
[Music]
Mexican government and Pemex
announcement of building a new refinery
raises many doubts so far all the
contractors that have been participating
in the bidding claims that the
conditions the government requested were
not realistic they want a refinery too
early for too little money but I guess
we're going to have to wait to 2022 to
see who's right bus we can already judge
the success of the education reform this
is another project started by the
previous president that was stopped by
an like in this case Mexico had a unique
educational system in most countries
teachers have to pass an exam in order
to be hired by a public school but not
in Mexico in this case it's the teachers
union that controls the hiring process
and a teaching position can be sold or
even inherited yep yeah that right you
can inherit a teacher's job from your
father and you don't even need to prove
that you know the subjects that you're
going to teach this is why Mexico
changed the system and introduced a
national exam
it would be changed to a system similar
to Spain's but in Mexico the change
sparked extremely violent protests
especially in the south of the country
thousands of teachers retired before
having to pass the exam and more than a
thousand teachers were fired because
after three attempts they could have
passed most of them of course got
another job at the administration but
don't worry this is all history one of
the most vocal and low supporters during
the campaign were those teachers unions
so while now he's returning the favor by
going backwards on all those reforms so
a Mexican teachers will once again enjoy
their privileges and Mexican kids will
keep failing all their exams but by far
the most controversial thing amlet has
done involves his war against the narcos
[Music]
when Mexico was ruled by the right-wing
it passed the law to allow the military
to fight the narcos this definitely
didn't work in the last 12 years Mexico
has had more than 250,000 deaths linked
directly to the war on drugs and Lopez
promised that he would stop the war so
what did he do well instead of using the
military he's created a brand new body
called the National Guard dance who's a
part of this National Guard well of
course that would be former soldiers
even the leader is a former military
officer so basically AMLO changed
everything to keep everything the same
and the same is happening with lots of
social programs and even the Mexico City
Airport we talked about that before and
you might think that he did it to save
money but not really that money is being
reinvested in another project with a
more dubious utility and that's the
Mayan train this train will cross the
southern Mexico States which would be
great if those regions were more
developed so with no people or goods to
transport it's wishful thinking to
believe that this is going to push
developments in the region but well this
still isn't the worst thing
my end organizations ask AMLO to stop
the construction of the Mayan train so
far the project hasn't passed any of the
environmental impact studies but still a
Malays administration keeps on trying in
this political climate where the
president isn't listening to anybody
it's easy to understand why foreign
investors are leaving the country by the
Dozen and this has already had an impact
on the country's economic growth so now
we must ask you do you think Hamlet will
manage to avoid a recession in Mexico or
do you think that the money that's
running away from the country will never
come back
well please leave your answer in the
comments section below and don't forget
to visit reconsider mediacom the
podcasts the providers of vocals in this
episode that were not mine also we've
published brand new videos every week so
please do subscribe to visual politic
and hit that Bell button so you won't
miss any posts and if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up and as always
I'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and here
even